[Music]
my name is Matata Mel I am a developer
advocate at Google based in London hi
I'm James word I'm a developer advocate
in Colorado first of all thanks for
being here
so early in the morning after the after
party if you went there I'm impressed
today we're going to be talking about
multi regional apps on Google Cloud so
when you think about multi regionality
there's actually two aspects to that the
first one is running your code in a
multi regional way and that's what we're
gonna cover here today in this
presentation but the second aspect is
storing your data in a multi regional
way unfortunately we won't have time to
cover that today so sorry about that
because once we went through figuring
out what it takes to run your code in a
multi regional way we realized it's
really complicated maybe much more
complicated it should be so we have just
enough time to cover that but the good
news is that we talk to the solution
engineers guys at Google who is really
interested in this topic and they're
gonna come up with some solution papers
in the next few months on running your
code multi regionally and and strong
your data multi regionally so that
people can get an idea on what to do on
both phones because it doesn't make
sense to have your code running montt
originally when your data is in a single
region so with that first let's talk
about why we should even care about
multi regional T so James you want to
tell us more about that yep
so we many others have data centers all
around the world and we we have this
compute spread all over the place and so
why would we actually want to have all
these data centers all around the world
so I want to give an example of New York
to Tokyo let me know how many miles it
is from New York to Tokyo guesses six
thousand seven hundred and thirty seven
miles I think that's like straight line
so it's a lot of miles right but we all
think like hey you know our data is
traveling via light and light is really
fast but it actually turns out light
isn't really fast at that
a scale somebody know how long it takes
light to travel from New York to Tokyo
and back Jess's it's actually 72
milliseconds so just to get light from
New York to Tokyo and back take 72
milliseconds and that may not seem like
a lot that's you know only 72
milliseconds but in a typical web
application and the way that TCP works
we're actually making these
back-and-forth things all the time over
and over and over just to load like one
web page and so this adds up and stacks
on top of each other to create a lot of
really high latency for our users so if
our data center is in New York and our
user is in Tokyo then this latency can
really add up and create a bad
experience for them so by moving the the
actual service of what we're serving in
the app that we're serving as close as
we can to the user we can really
significantly reduce the latency that
our users experience so that's that's
one big reason for why we may want to be
multi-regional in our application it's
just to reduce latency in our
application for our users and then this
also definitely comes into play as we're
communicating across microservices so if
we have microcircuits one is in New York
and one is in Tokyo and those micro
services are gonna have high latency
communicating with each other as well so
not necessarily just about user
experience could be service integration
experience to you and latency around
that so then another reason to be
multi-regional is just to be able to to
protect ourselves against outages a lot
of times when outages happen there they
should be pretty isolated but sometimes
they can propagate up and these can be
because an engineer like me makes a
mistake or it could be because of some
major catastrophic act of god and so by
being able to be multi regional we can
now avoid some of those issues around
outages so let's talk about how we
actually
we build a multi regional architecture
to handle these scenarios to reduce
latency and to to deal with with outages
so we're going to start at what we call
the zone level so the zone level you can
think of a zone essentially as an
isolated data center that is protected
from from other other outages or other
issues and others known so it's has this
isolation so it is essentially a data
center with its own network its own
power its own backup power all those
things together and so we're gonna start
with the zones our apps always will run
in a specific zone and so we need that's
essentially getting down to the server
level we've got to run on a server at
some point and that server is going to
be in a data center which you can think
of as a zone then we have this idea of
aggregating together different zones
into a region and so if you want to your
application to be able to be resilient
across across the region that needs to
exist in multiple zones because
potentially a whole zone could go out if
there's something crazy that happens in
the data center somebody makes a mistake
in a network configuration or something
like that can take out a whole zone so
if you want to be resilient at the
regional level you need to be spread
across multiple zones and so we have
many different regions that you can
choose from and there's us West there's
a couple in u.s. quest there's Tokyo
there's Europe all sorts of different
regions that you can choose from but
region is just an aggregation of
multiple zones for your application to
run in so we've got these we've got
these multiple regions and that's great
but we don't want to tell users in Tokyo
hey you need to go to food Tokyo calm
and users in Europe to say oh you got to
go to Fuu Europe calm all right that's
not going to work we want to send them
to phu kham and so then we have to have
some way to be able to give them a
single
endpoint that then will route traffic to
their nearest region that they're in and
this is what a global load balancer does
is it provides us a single IP address
and that's a single domain name
that we can give to our users or to our
services and it then looks at the
request and where it's coming from and
we'll route it to the the closest
location and make sure that what it's
routing it to is up and able to handle
requests so then our users are happy
because our users in Tokyo automatically
go to the Tokyo region service so great
so that's that's how our global load
balancer works but let's actually take a
look at what this actually looks like so
I'm gonna start here I've got this is
gonna get a little tricky because we're
running two different windows our our
Chrome browser on the left is running
actually running the browser itself is
actually running on a virtual machine in
Europe and then our Chrome browser on
the right is a virtual machine running
in organ so left Europe right organ
maybe we should have done that the other
way geographically but that's okay ok so
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to load
an application here and you'll see the
address for this application that's 35
to 44 right we're gonna load that same
address in the other one as well but
what this app is doing is when it loads
it figures out where the application is
actually running so not where the user
is coming from but where the application
is actually running so this application
is running in Belgium so it's in the
Belgian region and then it tells us how
the ping time that it took how long it
took for the client which is also in
Belgium in this case to make the request
to the region in Belgium and get a
response so it was pretty quick forty
nine milliseconds and then it shows us a
nice picture of Belgium of st. Chris and
Chris Lane and Belgium there okay so
that's great but what we're gonna do now
is go to that same exact address but
we're gonna do it from Oregon and now
the app says hey I'm running in Oregon
and we get pretty good latency there 121
milliseconds and we see a weird picture
of a building from The Dalles in and
organ that's great same address see
that's the key with this whole thing is
we went to the same address and that
address routed us to the region that was
closest to where our request was coming
from so now we're able to get much lower
latencies if I were in my organ virtual
machine to go directly so I'm not going
to go through the load balancer I'm
going to go directly to my Europe region
we try to load that you'll see that now
my much my latency is much higher right
so I'm now accessing I just bypassed the
the load balancer and now my latency is
much higher up to 361 milliseconds so
not look terrible but you know if we
have to stack a bunch of requests on top
of each other this is gonna get really
slow really quick so let's go back
through the load balancer here and see
things are much faster when we access
the region that's closest to us there's
one other thing here that we can do is
we can go in and let's simulate a
catastrophic disaster in Oregon so I'm
just gonna actually do that by turning
off all my instances in Oregon so we'll
turn all those off it'll take a second
for them to shut down but now if we go
back and now we try to access from organ
this application and we'll have to wait
a second for them to actually shut down
but what's going to happen is it's going
to now say like I can't access the stuff
that's closest to you so I'm instead
gonna route you to a server err or her
it shouldn't have there we go the
bail-jumping
so it's now routing us to Belgium
instead of that that service that was
down so now we get that that
fault-tolerance across those regions
just built in and of course things are
gonna be much slower while that that
organ system is down but at least it
hasn't crashed and it's just not not
working for users so there we go that's
that's how we now have our global load
balancer that is able to route stuff to
the closest the closest application to
the user and handle outages across this
okay and let's go back and scale that
back up so that future
damas work just thank you all right cool
so that was good for the high level
description of what an app should look
like that's a tolerant and
multi-regional but how do you do this on
Google cloud before we talk about that
we need to talk about how you can run
code on Google cloud because it's a
little bit complicated there's a lot of
options so let's go through those
options first one by one look at the
options that you have when you run your
code and then take a quick look of how
to turn that code running in a single
region and make a multi-regional now
let's take a look at this from low level
to high level at the lowest level in
Google Cloud there's compute engines
these are basically virtual machines
running Windows or Linux instances in a
single region you basically choose the
CPU you want the memory you want the
storage you want and the VM is ready in
30 seconds and then once you have it you
can install whatever you want it's yours
it's not maintained so you had to take
care of software updates and everything
but it's yours to keep and it's mostly
for applications that you already have
running in a VM you want to move them to
Google Cloud you would mostly use
compute engine right then if you made
the switch to containers from VMs to
containers you probably heard about
Cuban ities which is an open source
project to manage containers and you
also probably heard about sto which is
also an open source project to manage
the traffic to your containers in Google
Cloud with a single single g-cloud
command command you can get a Cabana
test cluster with East your enabled so
with just a single command you have a
cluster running with kubernetes and sto
and that's where you would run your
continuous applications with full
flexibility so whatever you want to do
with your containers scale them connect
them cube entities gives you all that
flexibility and communities engine is
the place to run that on Google Cloud
now with flexibility comes a lot of
complexity because kubernetes has its
own vocabulary like pods and deployments
and services that you have to learn so
there can be a lot of complexity there
we introduced something called cloud run
a couple days ago which is a real
easy way of running containers in a
server this way so in cloud run you
basically point to your container and
then you just say deploy this container
and scale it for me and what Google
Cloud does is that it basically the
container routes to traffic to the
container takes care of scaling down to
zero and no one uses it scale up to
whatever you set automatically so all
those details are run in a container and
scaling up and down is taken care for
you and you don't have to deal with the
low-level details like you burn it is an
issue everything's like I don't abstract
it away from you but maybe you don't
even want to care about containers
because you know containers even though
there are nice abstractions you still
need to worry about writing a docker
file then you need to worry about your
dependencies and make sure that your
local file is actually optimized so it
doesn't take too long to load your
container and things like that so you
maybe as an application developer you
want to deal with source code and not
the infrastructure and for that there's
App Engine App Engine has been around
for a long time I and it's kind of
service before service was popular in
App Engine you write your code deploy it
and you still get kind of service
features like scaling down to zero and
scaling up easily but you also get
traffic splitting versioning and other
features like dashboards and things like
that for free and finally maybe you
don't even care about applications you
just want to write some piece of code in
a function define the input and the
output and define what triggers that
function and let Google manage the rest
so for that there's cloud functions so
that's for source based event-driven
applications right so this is the stack
that you have when it comes to running
code on Google Cloud and it's up to you
basically where you want to be in the
stack the low-level of compute engine or
at the highest level at cloud functions
but the key thing is that all of these
options they're basically they're always
running in a zone in a region so they're
not really designed to be multi-regional
by default they're not even designed to
be regional by default they're designed
to run in a single spot single zone in a
region so you have to do work yourself
to make a multi regional and at the high
level this is how it looks like so for
compute engine
there's
Google's global HTTP HTTPS load balancer
so there's really good support for that
so you would base a set that up so you
would deploy two VMs in two different
regions and you would set up the web
answer in front of them and and that
there's good support for that now if
you're on kubernetes engine and it still
and things are a little more complicated
so there's so if you're running
kubernetes on google cloud or or on-prem
or orders or some other place there's
Cuba's Federation and there's two
versions of that that we'll talk about
there's a tool called cube mci that
helps you to set up an HTTP load
balancer in front of your cube artists
clusters that we'll talk about as well
but it's a temporary solution there is
something called multi cluster ingress
with gke that we announced last next but
it's not ready yet
so you cannot use it today and finally
if you are using is T of your traffic
management there is a way to configure
it co so that it spans multiple clusters
and that's also an option so the story
that is complicated and hopefully we'll
get to the bottom of it at the end of
this presentation and then for quad run
and app engine code functions
unfortunately Google Club doesn't
support any native solution today so
what that means is that you need to
deploy them yourself in multiple regions
and used to figure out a load balancer
in front of them yourself something like
Apogee or CloudFlare or nginx or
something like that but we'll talk about
all of these in detail as we go through
the presentation now first let's talk
about compute engine now if you want to
deploy code to compute engine one wrong
way of doing that is that you get a VM
you install whatever you want on the VM
and you repeat the process right this
works for like maybe five VMs but if you
have to manage like thousands of VMs it
doesn't work it doesn't scale and it's
error-prone right what you need to do is
first of all you need to create what's
called an instance template and from the
instance template you need to create an
instance group to manage these VMs
but to get to the instance tablet you
need to do a little bit of work so let's
go through that let's see how to create
an instance memory force first you start
with the base image
Google Cloud has a lot of base images
that you can rely on for Windows and
Linux
or you can also input your own image if
you want into your project and use it as
well by either way you start with an
image and you get a VM running from the
VM you can install other things that you
need on that VM and once it's ready you
can take a snapshot of that VM so this
snapshot basically takes the snapshot or
the the this that the VM is attached to
and then you can use that disk for to
create other VMs but the snapshot is
project scoped meaning you can only use
that within the same project you usually
have multiple projects and you want to
be able to share this snapshot with
multiple projects so for that you create
something called custom image so custom
in the image is basically a snapshots
that you can share globally with
multiple projects but you don't usually
take the custom image and running as it
is because different regions and
different apps need different
configuration so what you usually do is
that you take a custom image and you use
startup scripts and you use metadata
service to get configuration and setup
into your custom images so that they are
customized for the region that you're
running and from then you can create an
instance tablet right so that's kind of
like the journey to instance tablet so
it's the step with basically kind of
combines the custom image and the
startup scripts and the metadata
together into a template that you can
use to create groups of instances and
finally you can use called API to create
these instance groups so the Claddagh
API you can use it from g-cloud command
line tool so when you use g-cloud
command line tool it uses the API or you
can use the client libraries in any
language you want or you can use the
REST API directly if you want by either
way you're going through the cloud API
to create these groups so from the
instance template we you create
something called instance groups these
are basically groups of VMs that are
managed for you they are based on a
template on an instance template and
these instance groups basically once you
create an instance group it manages the
VMS for you so if a VM goes down or if
it's not healthy it will bring it down
and create a new one for you
you can also set auto scaling on these
instances so you can set for example the
min and the max size all these instances
as you seen in
James's demo you can easily scale down
to zero manually or scale up or you can
also set auto scaling but the key thing
is that although this is still a single
zone or multiple zones but they're still
within the same region so it's not
multi-regional yet and as I mentioned
you can hook up an auto scaler to your
instance group and you can set policies
on that so you can say for example I
want to scale from 0 to 20 and I want to
be able I want to do this with CPU so
the auto scale we look at the average
CPU and it will scale up and down it
will basically instruct instance group
to scale up and down depending on the
policy that you have but although this
is still single region so you might be
wondering like why are you showing me
all this because it's single region and
James won't tell us about that yep so
when we create our instance groups and
our instance templates that's in a
single region so we need to be able to
take that to multiple regions and then
put the load balancer in front of that
so the solution is to put the load
balancer in front of our multiple
regions so we need to set up the
instance templates which can span
multiple regions but then we need to run
our instance group so we'll run an
instance group in East or West and in
Europe so we'll run our instance groups
every region that we want to provide
service in and then we put the global
load balancer or the Google load
balancer in front of that so the way
that we do that is we first need our
global IP address so we go and reserve a
global IP address for our load balancer
so the load balancer will have a single
reserved IP address that we use across
the whole world and then we set up a
forwarding rule so the request is going
to come in to the load balancer which is
a machine running in a data center
somewhere and then it needs to know what
to do with that request and so we tell
it hey here's what you do you need to
actually call this thing over here and
so that goes through a proxy so we set
up a proxy which is going to allow us to
do some URL Maps and ultimately the
proxy is going to point to our back-end
service which is running in a specific
region so we're going to tell our load
balancer about all the regions that our
application is up and
and to find those all his back-end
services underneath the load balancer
and then those actually can can forward
the request to our app that's actually
running within a region and then within
a zone so those are actual backends so
the path that this goes through on the
Internet is that the end user is going
to make a request ultimately to an IP
address that IP address is going to
resolve to the region that is closest to
them and I think we use like multihoming
or something like that to magic tricks
with multihomed IP addresses to make
that work but that IP address routes
them to the closest region where there's
a machine the load balancer running
that's going to handle that request look
up the information for where - for where
it can Ford that requests - and then try
to get that request forwarded to the
region that is closest to the user and
then we can set up we have to set up
firewall rules which allow the load
balancer to talk to our instance group
so we need to make that request possible
we and our set up just expose through
the firewall rules access to the world
to our back-end services and you
probably wouldn't want to do that you
probably want to restrict it so that
only the load balancer can actually make
requests to your actual backing instance
groups so you set up your firewall rules
and then you set up a health check so
the health check is a URL that the load
balancer is going to be periodically
calling and then that's what tells the
load balancer that that region is good
and can handle requests so that's how we
set up the load balancer but let's see
what it actually looks like here so in
the Google cloud platform console first
we're going to go check out our let's go
to our instance templates so you see
that we have a couple different ones
here but the one that we showed you
already was this one and so this was
where we went and created the template
of how to create instance groups in the
multiple regions so there's a few things
that that we have specified in here the
there is the the firewall configuration
that is specified through this network
tag issue TP tag
there's the container image that we're
pulling down from the the container
repository image information so what
size CPU to use and that sort of thing
so that's our instance template and then
from there we created our instance
groups so there's the instance group in
Europe that we were using and the
instance group in Oregon that we are
using and so if we go into one of these
instance groups we can see this is
really just created instances created
from a template and potentially auto
scaled so see it's pointing to that
instance auto scaling is off in our case
and then we have the actual instances
the two instances that are up and
running the application there so those
are our actual underlying instances for
this so that's the the structure
instance template which allows us to
create instance groups in multiple
regions and then the actual running
instances that are running within zones
okay so now let's take a look at the the
load balancer configuration so that's
under network services load balancing
and the load balancer that we've set up
that you've just seen is called web map
and here you'll see our public IP
address so that was the one if you
remember that I loaded at first in those
those browser windows so that's our
public load balancer IP address the
single IP address that we use to access
everything behind the load balancer and
then you'll see that I'm giving it the
instance groups the the Europe and
Oregon instance groups and then it knows
how to then route the traffic as you saw
and then we can go check out like our
health check here to see what that's
doing that's going to a URL slash ping
and some parameters around that health
check so that's how we put together the
load balancer along with the instance
templates and instance groups to make
this not just a regional application but
now a multi regional application great
and the key thing is that there's all
native support here from Google so you
didn't have to use anything external and
you get the Geo
balancing for free the global world
bouncer does figures out where the user
is and routes to requests to the nearest
instance group so that's the that's the
key thing now for Cuban it is engine in
this do things are a little bit more
complicated so let's go through that so
the landscape is that so if you are
running kubernetes there used to be a
feature called kubernetes federation a
version one there was a group that
worked on that for a year or so I think
and then it was abandoned because it
didn't like didn't handle a little use
cases and it wasn't stable and all that
kind of stuff and now there's a v2
coming up there's another group that's
working on that and last time I checked
it's still evolving I haven't seen I
think it's either out for a better stage
but I haven't seen it being used in
production yet but if you're using Cuban
it is inside or outside Google cloud you
should keep an eye on kubernetes
Federation maybe v2 will get to the
final stage and maybe it will be you
will be able to use it but as well today
I didn't feel like it was something that
you can use in production now in gke in
google kubernetes engine the clusters
are actually deployed in a single zone
in a single region there is something
called regional gke clusters meaning you
can have a GK classroom
spanning multiple zones but those are
still in a single region right but one
thing that you can do is that you can
you can create two clusters in two
separate regions yourself you can kind
of world balance between them if you
want this works but it's manual and you
need to make these two independent
clusters that you need to manage and you
need to load balanced set up some kind
of a bunch of yourself now there's a
tool called multi cluster ingress and
there's a command-line tool called cube
mci that's open source and it's
supported by Google and if you look at
Google G caiis
documentation page on cube mci right at
the top there's a red font message that
says this is on the temporary don't
don't use it but I'm gonna show it here
today for because of unfortunate reasons
that I'm gonna explain but basically
that that's a tool that you can use to
set up two clusters in two regions
and load-balanced I'm using Google's
HTTP load balancer kind of like compute
engine but it kind of automates that for
you so you don't have to do all those
steps yourself cube MCI does it for you
so you might wonder like okay if keeps
the FCI is temporary then what am I
going to use and ultimately you will be
you'll be using something called multi
class to ingress come to control or MCI
that we announced last next in July but
we last time I checked it's still in
progress and I I asked the PM can can we
have a version that we can play with and
I couldn't get one yet so it's in
progress but eventually that will
replace cube MCI and maybe next year
I'll show you them all that but not
today
so what I'm going to do is I'm gonna
talk about cube MC today but keep in
mind that it's gonna it's a temporary
solution until the other MCI which is
implemented using ingress control rule
comes along now cube MCI it's a
command-line tool that you can use to
load balance between two separate
clusters deploy to multiple regions but
there are some restrictions each service
must be configured exactly the same way
meaning that you need to have the same
name unit so they need to be in the same
namespace names and they need to expose
the same ports and they need to be the
service type node port yeah in in
communities so this might be limiting
for you but you have to basically do
this in order to use this tool and the
way to do it I'll just show you some
g-cloud command quickly so you having an
idea how to set this up first you need
to create your clusters so in Google
Cloud you just use g-cloud container
classes great give it a name define the
number of nodes define the zone so this
creates a cluster in Europe then you do
the same for us
so you have two clusters running one in
Europe one in us then to get your code
into Cuban it is you create a deployment
so you create a deployment
Yama file with the your container image
and stuff like that and you have your
code running then you need to expose
your pod pod to the outside world so for
that we're gonna use a notepad service
because that that's what cube mci it
forces us to do so we do that as well
and then you need to let cube mci manage
your cluster and to do that you
basically get the credentials of your
your cluster and
save to a cube config file so I'm
getting the credentials of my Europe
West and the credentials on my us West
save to a file and then finally I need a
static IP for my ingress
so I reserved that static IP on Google
Cloud and then I point I create an
ingress resource for for my cube MCI
right so I basically create a llamo file
that defines my ingress that I'm gonna
show in the next slide and I point to my
project and I point to my cube cube
config the configuration for mark for my
MSA config so once you do that the cube
MC I can list like the ingress IP for
you if you want you can see the status
and then then you get an IP and you can
crawl that IP and get your cluster right
so these are kind of the steps and just
to show you I am NOT going to show you
the deployment or the service because
these are Cuban these things that you
should probably know about already if
you are running humanities but the llamo
file for the ingress kind of looks like
this you basically say this is my
service name this is the port that I
want to expose my you know external load
balancer basically and then you add
couple orientations so you are saying
this is my static IP name so this is the
IP name like that i had when i created
my static IP in google cloud and also
there an ingress class that tells me
this is a multi cluster setup so once
you have this you can expose these two
clusters in two separate regions using
ingress with cube mci and yeah let me
show you this and it's not going to be
too different than what we had before
but if I come back here
instead of going to Google compute
engine instance I'm going to gke
instance and one thing that you realize
is that this is on HTTP not HTTPS
because I was too lazy to set it up
sorry if I come here then it's the same
kind of thing like from Europe I go to
Europe from us I go to us and if you
look at the configuration for so the
cube entities engine I have two clusters
one is where am i Europe West and the
other one is where my US West so these
are micro business clusters and if you
look at the services
I have the ingress services and the
Northport services that are also exposed
that I need and if you look at the load
balancers so this was the load balancer
for for compute engine but I also have a
load balancer for the cube mci and
that's pointing to the ingress is the
back-end services basically in
communities so that's that's how it is
and so let's kubernetes with that Sto
but if you are running many more
services on kubernetes and if you want
to manage the traffic to my services
then it makes sense to use Kuban steer
and normally it still runs in a single
region for example there's this book
info application that you probably have
seen on issue it's a sample application
that has multiple micro services unusual
these are deployed in a single region
but there is a way to set sto in a multi
cluster way where you can spend multiple
clusters and these clusters can be in
multiple regions so in this case for
example we have one of the my services
reviews b2 running in uswest and another
one running in us east so you can do
this kind of setup in multi cluster sto
I tried this it works and if you go to
East your documentation page there's a
couple of different flavors that you can
use to set this up but we won't go
through it here today because this is
like a little complicated and too many
steps but it's something that actually
works and then you can use as well right
ok so that wraps up the kubernetes is
still part and let's talk about cloud
run and App Engine and cost functions
learned yep moving up the stack so if
you want a higher abstraction level
instead of doing GCE or kubernetes you
want to move up to cloud run or App
Engine let's talk about how that works
so for our server list compute there's
different abstraction layers cloud
functions App Engine and cloud run and
the way that you set up these to be
multi-regional varies a little bit so I
want to run through that so if you're on
App Engine
when you create an app in Google Cloud
it's tied to a specific project and you
can only have one app one App Engine app
in a given project and each app has a
single region so in App Engine there's
this correlation of one project has one
app which is tied to a single region so
if you want to be multi regional with
App Engine what that means is you need
to set up multiple projects and each
project one project for each region that
you want to be in so that's what we have
to do for App Engine to be multi
regional for Club functions we can have
multiple functions in a given project so
that's good
but each the actual function in our
project is tied to a specific region so
if we want to have a multi regional
function then we need to have multiple
instances of that function multiple
functions essentially in different
regions and then for cloud run that will
also be true but today cloud run I think
only works in central the central region
so today only one region for cloud runs
so we can't quite be multi regional yet
I'm sure that's coming but when it when
we do have multiple regions it's very
similar to cloud functions so each time
we create a deployment in cloud run
essentially our app then then that runs
in a specific region so we need to have
multiple ones but at least it we can
have multiple cloud run apps or project
deployments within a given project so
now for all of these options today you
have to use an external load balancer so
the apogee is a great option because
that's something that is as part of the
Google family just not fully integrated
into like the Google console and that
kind of thing yet but great option or
you could use another load balancer as
well so those are your options from the
server load side of things for how you
go multi-regional one thing to add here
but we are working on a more Google
cloud native solution load balancing
solutions for all of these it's not
there yet but it's something that that
we are working on but for now we have to
rely on something external like a PJ
o'clair or something
an RPG I don't think I will do justice
to Apogee because it's such a
complicated product that I but I only
use a small part of that but what is
Apogee is that it used to be a separate
company that Google bought like two or
three years ago it's an API proxy and
API management tool so you can basically
you know set a proxy that points to
either servers or points to like any
endpoints running anywhere not just on
Google Cloud and then you can set very
complicated rules on those endpoints so
you can do pre flows which means when
you someone hits that endpoint you can
run some code then then then you can do
post flows where which means that when
someone comes out of the code you can do
some complicated things you can load
balance between anything really like any
endpoint you can work bounce balance you
can set pretty much any kind of role you
want on that they have a really good
developer console where you can
visualize things and see how the traffic
is flowing
you can even debug your endpoints from
the console that I'm gonna show and
there's many other things like machine
learning intrusion detection and all
sorts of stuff that I haven't played
with but just know that it's if you need
any kind of API management
Appaji is a really great tool now what I
use it for is that you know if we have
engine applications and we had app
engine endpoints all I wanted to do is
that I want to have a single end point
where I can load but I can do geo load
balancing so if a user is in uswest
I want them to go to us West App Engine
and if they're in Europe I want them to
go to Europe so I just set that up with
Apogee and it was really easy and really
intuitive so let me just show you some
of that so this is the App Engine
console so it's a separate console it's
not part of Google cloud so you have to
work with that you can set many proxies
that you want API proxies but here I
have a proxy for my multi-regional app
and then what you can see is that
there's product tests so you don't have
to push everything to port by default
you can test them out in the test
environment and once you're ready you
can push them to prod and then under
here you can see the endpoints that we
are exposing so the
multi-region - SML is my base end point
but then /g AE is my App Engine endpoint
slash cloud run is my cloud run endpoint
and stuff like that
so these are what's called proxy
endpoints I have a default one and I
also have specific ones for specific
products like G App Engine or run Oracle
functions and then these proxy endpoints
they point to target endpoints and this
target endpoints basically there are
things that you define they can be some
endpoints in Google Cloud or they can be
endpoints anywhere really the default
one by the way this is the kind of UI
part but you can also switch to
developer mode and in developer mode you
can see things in a way that makes more
sense at least to me in XML so for
example the default one I'm saying that
it's a secure endpoint meaning I'm gonna
use HTTP and my target endpoint is
default as well if you look at the
target endpoint i have to service
defined and i'm just round robin in
between them so these servers i defined
what their IP is what their port is and
it will run bob in between them if you
look at the App Engine one here I'm
saying my base endpoint is / ji GAE and
it's also a secure endpoint and then my
target endpoint is GAE row west and GAE
uswest
- and I also have a condition right and
in this condition I'm saying that if the
system has a region name that starts
with Europe then send it to your quest
and if the system region name starts
with us
sent to us west so that's how that's how
I'm doing a geoweb balancing with Apogee
and if we look at these target endpoints
GAE West it's basically just my App
Engine in url so this is multi region in
the Europe and this is multi region -
which is in the u.s. so that's how you
set it up and once we have that you can
also do tracing kind of things maybe but
maybe I want yeah I won't show that here
because it's not showing up here but
basically you can also trace these from
the the console and see where the
request is going in which conditions are
being met and stuff like that but for
some reason it's not showing up here
right now this
yeah it is scaling over this is a little
bit weird yeah so that's how you set
things up and I guess you can show us
how it works in yeah so it's the App
Engine side so over in Google called
console I'll show you the App Engine
parts of this so if we go to App Engine
remember I can only have one App Engine
app within a single project and so our
project is this multi-regional atom l
and this is my App Engine app and so we
can go in and look at the services I've
got service there with multiple versions
took us a little bit of testing and get
everything up and running and then
underneath the App Engine we're using
App Engine flex so there's actual
instances underneath that as well
so these run ultimately on GC instances
underneath the covers so that's one app
if we can go just to actually load this
thing and you can see it so this is not
going through the load balancer just
going direct to this particular
application so all the way to Belgium
took a round-trip was five hundred and
sixty-seven milliseconds so pretty long
there to get to you Belgium and back
okay so now to be multi-regional we
needed another project so we can go
select to it o search the dictionary
there we go let's try this again okay so
we've got another project here
multi-region
to add to mel and so now we're in the
App Engine 1 for that and we've
configured this App Engine app to run in
us West and so if we go load that then
we get our Los Angeles one there so very
similar same container image that this
is based on the same application
underneath of covers okay so that's our
App Engine and then of course we can go
test out the load balancer part of this
as well so if we go to our end point for
our apogee then we remember left is
belgium so it routed us correctly to
belgium and then if we load that same
end point and from our organ then you'll
see that i don't know why we picked los
angeles but anyways it's it's now going
from Oregon where we're
the VM on the right is running down to
Los Angeles and back so a little bit
higher latency should be a little bit
faster than that but um never try it
again there we go that's a little better
so it did rout us to the closest one it
didn't rout us to Belgium so that's good
so there we go that's that's Apogee now
running in front of the App Engine apps
[Music]